how's gum rest my name is Barbra welcome
back to condom Edie we are back in this
office with a really really ugly girl oh
god she sees me
oh god okay we're good okay all right so
we got the super taser in the last
episode grab a paper plastic well calm
down
paper cut your thing I only got your
friend I only wanted your friend
sup baby my name what's your name man
rock wind okay that makes sense okay doc
he'll know her name what the hell is
lagging man lagging all right
we are back with Sammi sir whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa
Sammi what the hell is going on oh dude
it is [ __ ] creeper man leaves it's a
bee suit is something I kill your friend
man that's Locker what did you do to him
you painted in blue or you will pay for
this or what I'll pay for this
Sammi sue what do they do
I don't know what you do you suck no I
don't you what the hell are you doing
girl you don't throw mister [ __ ] or what
hold you we weren't alone you [ __ ] them
on [ __ ] a working computer shoot a bear
dick she touched me inappropriately oh
oh she's oh sure she's going down
okay I'm going through the window yeah
of course
sorry mr. Sher gotta continue with Simon
soo okay penny just don't trust her I
don't trust anything that looks like
that man don't worry bro I got my eyes
on you girl and hang in there that's
funny that's funny you see that it's a
search engine specific to the library
huh
Joseph - I hate mondays and he's a
monkey a unique art I love unicorns
taste that [ __ ] seriously are you a
robot or something [ __ ] it I'm gonna
hacks computers now all right it's every
day of peterpan
connect don't worry lady I got Li taxer
what did she disappear did she did
what's going on here don't trust this
eMeter she went into my brain didn't she
androids can do that
all right sorry room it is
oh that's right kill that [ __ ] goddamn
it don't fight back all right
that murderer god damn it hello mom
ain't alright
hey don't swearing Sammy Sosa presents
Rosa Rosa are you there
that didn't really sound a little Rosa
the Rose has been abducted I know I
don't really want to but I guess me and
Sammy has to go we gotta go
I know that's for just what I said time
you say why don't you pay attention I'm
sorry why don't you just cut paper like
you're supposed to
alright let's go in here I don't know by
exit that's pretty nice let's go there
god damn it Tommy we can't go today
actually
I know Sammy I know we have to find her
stop stating the obvious it's 5:00 in
the morning holy [ __ ]
I should be dreaming about that bird
collection you would be a fine
collecting thing you will be called
Frodo that's right
Frodo let's look for some evidence
oh I see something over here what is
this Sammy let's take it
ah yes god damn you
it's five five six clients restored okay
it's stored for future references family
so don't worry it looks like Rosa phone
is on the server am I playing songs
right now
sounds like aliens and their ways it's
pretty nice how that happened
I can't tap out of this game stop it
Sammy no that was like a commercial
thank God I'm starting my own baby
god dammit wait a second roommate
alright we are back here looking at
birds where's the server room
information services what whoa what
Sammy do something all right here we go
whoa
hi guys sucked I guess the super taser
is like super effective P Kat you got a
critical hit all right
pig oh we got my fire axe pig ah ja it's
super effective ha ha Pikachu use
Thunderbolt
anyone else want a thunderbolt ace I
know you have my ID hey don't shoot me
bro
the grass back down oh sorry it's timing
I would have to use it AG gotten a
little bit shocked I panicked see you
later Sammy sir they were quite the
gentle girl I enjoyed you all right [ __ ]
it see well come on man don't [ __ ] with
me don't play games with me
that's right anyway that's what a tango
ah you see what I did to root what's
your name man roben oh you see what I
did to Ruben whoa whoa whoa whoa don't
play games
wouldn't oh [ __ ] me I'm screwed I'm
screwed Sammy come back to me I'm scared
I'm scared to look at that guy's out
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you man dude don't think I
see you in your fake yo drinky sneak
it's snooker ha damn he got me ah [ __ ]
me I'll see in a second rise
[Music]
come on [ __ ] let's try all right
we're back you're taking a [ __ ] back
there or something sounds like it oh did
that hurt oh you're gonna go cry to mama
alright thank you for this pump shutting
oh you want probably not a good idea to
drop your shotgun for a piece of wood
just for future references BAM
oh it hurts doesn't it oh you're angry
now hey [ __ ] you man can't you see I'm
busy you're the one who killed me before
wasn't it why you're not dead that's
right alright we're back right here with
me [ __ ] I need all right what are you
doing whoa chill out man chill out chill
out chill out chill out where is he got
your beds
burns doesn't it that hurts even mine
finishes in love with a boot all right
let's go back with deodorant and shop
down this door
jinkx is colored he uses baloney no food
no tobacco
there's fairness that's right
Sabri room is here feel no fear
alright let's investigate that's
investigate own life where am I going to
investigate makes no sense I don't see
anything
it's probably like a fingerprint on one
of the lockers and sad
now I need to make it
I mean need to make it more dark maybe I
can [ __ ] up this lamp
laughs you're ruining my evidence
searching all right here we go now there
we go is she somehow clear now all those
others receive it just me Hey
grab the crowbar Oh No
is this main floor what there's the
terminal activity in rare books it may
be a Rosa all right so what I do with it
what'd I do with it laughs [ __ ] me I'm
going out I think we need the crowbar
over here
well maybe it's over one of the things I
don't know I think I left hand to the
hip rez like if a division guy this guy
to come right today and I'll see you
next so don't have tried of me
Southworth you're doing you sliding on
the stache ah what the hell man I'm
going to the bathroom and taking a
[ __ ] pest I'm get a pest how much